hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to carrots and cream now
this game was recommended to me because
they said it was bizarre and intriguing
and right up my alley and when I went to
the website all the other reviews said
that it was a life-changing my voting
experience and I don't know how true
that is but let's go because I hear a
pot of oh I was I was a bit disturbed by
the pot of what I was hoping stew Oh God
and now I'm thinking that it was a pot
of boiling blood probably oh geez
all right how's it going is that a
shovel I'm gonna assume that's a shovel
and I need to up right on target a
little bit off but I mean it seems like
normal everyday life but it's just a
slightly perturbing setting what with
the I'm gonna assume it's a river of
flowing blood now and then the guy that
was enjoying carrots and cream far too
much in the midst of my ear and now
we're just gonna be picking more carrots
so we can do this all over again
is this the is it C existential crisis
the endless cycle of carrots and cream I
don't even want to know where I get the
cream oh the cream is that gonna be part
of this game later ah [ __ ] I missed
there we go that was more on target
definitely not cutting my carrot in half
oh we're done oh we got enough little
garden to 5 carrots there's more than
enough all right why are you shaking so
much I think this guy is shaking from
lack of nutrition from everything else
that he hasn't had in its life oh God
oh well this seems this seems perfectly
normal nothing weird about this
just chopping carrots into a bowl of
what I assumed to be cream what type of
cream we're gonna discuss but it's a
type of cream while the perpetual like
Fountain of Youth behind me is bubbling
furiously away and I'm assuming there's
a numerous number of dead bodies in the
closets and in every nook and cranny in
the house
there's the murdered members of my
family because I'm clearly insane this
is a game that what's weird about is
that it's so kinda normal and presenting
other ways it's very disturbing like
something obviously what I've been doing
is I've just been gardening up carrots
and yet I am deeply perturbed
oh hello oh that a worm why is it
breathing why this is a ground shaking
so much why do we live in an earthquake
oh okay my poor little baby oh no I
didn't know that I was supposed to be
racing the gun here okay so I gotta inch
my way I'm assuming I'm assuming this
worm is gonna infant oh no oh this is
worms it's gonna eat through I thought I
thought for a second the worm was gonna
infect one of the carrots and then this
was gonna be the start of the zombie
apocalypse with his unhealthy obsession
with carrots and cream decides to
accidentally ingest one of these
horrible worms that's getting a little
close buddy you want to be I don't even
think this guy is going for the carrots
somehow he has Oh
he's eaten so many carrots he's gained
x-ray vision and he can see through the
ground what this worm is so he knows and
he's trying to stop him from taking all
his crops but you won't stop me buddy
boo I know exactly what I'm doing
in my life I don't know exactly what I'm
doing in this game but I like it I think
I think this is oh look at Big Mama care
over there oh hey baby how are you doing
oh boy my oh yeah I was just dangling it
with the end of oh no oh I was right oh
he's gonna eat this carrot he's gonna
become infested
oh the poor carrot of like the glorious
care that's a gigantic carrot but I knew
that this guy is unholy obsession with
these carrots is gonna be the end of him
someday
I mean you may have great vision that
can see through the ground but he can't
see why kids love the taste of cinnamon
toast crunch
I have to go on and play more games
today knowing that this experience will
tell me what do you want an intelligent
recap of what just happened you are
there you are there experience with me
it was bizarre because it seems so
normal
twists and turns and different sound
effects makes it a bizarre and
horrifying experience what that's
carrots and cream I guess so thank you
everybody so much for watching
as always I'll see you in the next video
bye bye